hello and welcome to this session of
blockchain myself surah Anam part of the
civil NT so let's get started to
understand what is blockchain what's in
it for you today let's discuss what are
the issues with today's current banking
system how Bitcoin has solved these
issues and how bitcoin is evolving
what is blockchain technology and what
are its features like public distributed
ledger how encryption works
proof-of-work algorithm and mining and
we will also discuss certain use cases
of blockchain money now what are the
current set of issues in today's banking
system in order to do any transaction on
a banking Channel today it costs a very
high transaction fees so suppose you
want to do a transfer of money from your
account to someone's else account
through a banking channel at the bank
might charge a fee for $200 transaction
up to five dollars and this receiver
will end up receiving one $95 which in
percentage terms is a very high
percentage of transaction fee also as of
today there's lot of scenarios people
end up doing double spending for example
over here the user has $800 in her
account but she ends up sending thousand
dollars $500 each to two users
double spending is a unique problem
where digital money is spent twice so
what does it tend to do is the user is
able to make two purchases with the
amount which is less than the purchase
value so in this scenario the lady was
able to buy a commodity worth more than
800 dollars though she only had eight
hundred dollars in our account also the
banking systems are prone to hacking
hackers attack financial institutions
and gain unauthorized access to data
they can do transactions on your behalf
which you are not aware of or they can
do the transfer of money
through some illegitimate accounts in
2017 the number of frauds in India to
ATM cards and net banking total to 1785
each amounting to more than 1 lakh rupee
so if you see the current banking system
is thrown to so many hacks that it can
amount to huge cost of money now how
Bitcoin can solve these problems
now bitcoin is a decentralized system so
which allows you to do a value transfer
transaction at a lower transaction fee
as low as one dollar as compared to the
five dollar which the bank was charging
and at the end the receiver receives the
true value of the amount which was sent
by the sender bitcoin follows a
decentralized system where no third
party like governments banks or any
other financial intermediary is involved
during the transaction between the
sender and receiver thereby reducing the
cost of transaction drastically and that
is the primary objective of
cryptocurrencies
all technologies like blockchain which
advocates the removal of intermediaries
now bitcoin is a cryptocurrency that
runs on blockchain now how Bitcoin
solved the problem of double spending
double spending is avoided through the
basic structure of blockchain which
involves verification of transactions so
in the previous example as we saw when
the user transferred $500 to the first
person then she will not be able to
transfer the another $500 based on the
basic validation of the blockchain and
we will see how suppose you are trying
to span the same Bitcoin in a second
transaction after the first transaction
has been confirmed the settling
transaction will not get verified and
thus become invalid and this will happen
because after the first transaction has
been confirmed your balance will be
verified in the second transaction your
address identity will be validated and
if suppose you are trying to spend more
than what the balance you have the
miners the validators of the blockchain
network will discard that particular
transaction and will not add it to the
main blockchain network thereby double
spending becomes as good as impossible
in a block thing each block is linked to
its previous block the transactions
become invalid for a specific Bitcoin
which has already been spent so you
can't spend the Bitcoin which we have
already spent public ledger a public
ledger records all Bitcoin transactions
where it is accessible to everyone who
is associated with the
system it is a 100% transparent system
any transaction happening is visible on
the public ledger once a user joins the
blockchain network he gets a copy of all
the blockchain transaction since its
initiation or inception and the first
block in a blockchain is called the
Genesis block though the public ledger
is accessible to everyone only the users
address and the transaction details are
visible to the users on the Bitcoin
network by looking at the address you
can't figure out to whom this address
belongs the identity is secured of the
address owner
this keeps blockchain safe from data
tampering each block and the blockchain
is aware of who is its previous block
and this with entire blockchain is
created even if a hacker tries to hack
one block it would have to change the
entire subsequent chain ahead of this
block which will require huge amount of
computation power for the hacker in
order to make the changes across all the
blocks which is next to impossible now
what is blockchain imagine two friends
living far away and would like to
transfer money using blockchain
technology blockchain is a decentralized
system of secure and trusted distributed
databases it's a distributed ledger
which records and share the transaction
details across many nodes which are part
of the network so that the data is not
modified so each and every transaction
which happens on a blockchain network it
distributed across all the nodes on the
blockchain each and every participant
has the same copy of the ledger and it's
an immutable ledger once a record or a
transaction is resisted it cannot be
modified blockchain was originally
introduced to timestamp digital
documents and prevent tampering of
records in simple terms a chain of
blocks that contain information it is
called blockchain now when a transaction
occurs its related information is
recorded into a block so as you see a
transaction initiated in one corner of
the globe can get registered on the
block and then that block is being
verified validated by the miners
the public ledger and then added to the
main block chain a block contains
aggregated transactions in a single
block which a minor has to validate and
in lieu of that the minor gets rewarded
now let's take a closer look at what all
are the components of a block so
whenever we talk about a blockchain what
is actually a block and what it consists
of now there are four major components
each block contains a previous hash data
data is nothing but the aggregation of
the transactions which are aggregated in
the block a nuance value and the hash of
the block itself now what is previous
hash previous hash is the attribute
which is connecting a block to its
previous block so the previous hash
attribute consists of the hash value of
its previous block data it consists the
details of the sender's address the
receivers address and the transaction
amount so basically they could be
multiple transactions amongst multiple
senders and receivers so each block will
consist n number of transactions and
each transaction will have a senders
address a receiver address and a
transactional nonce so basically the
Bitcoin uses a proof-of-work
algorithm and in order to execute the
algorithm nonce is a random value used
to vary the output of the hash value so
proof-of-work is the process of
transaction verification done in
blockchain hash hash is like a digital
fingerprint it is the fingerprint of the
current block now where it takes an
input value of the previous hash the
data and the nonce and produces an
output value of fixed length so Bitcoin
network uses sha-256 hashing algorithm
to generate a 256 bit length hash and
this is the output it looks something
like a hexadecimal value now what are
the features of blockchain a blockchain
is a decentralized public distributed
ledger that is used to record
transaction across many computers so
this is a sample transaction which you
are seeing these are set of three
transactions a transferring money to B B
to C and C to B a distributed ledger is
a database that is shared among all the
users who are part of the blockchain
network the try
actions are accessed and verified by
users associated to the Bitcoin network
thereby making it less prone to cyber
attacks it is actually enclosed within
all the participants who are part of the
network now let's take an example where
these Bitcoin users are transferring
money so here we have example like Bella
is trying to transfer money to John John
is trying to transfer money to Elsa and
Elsa is trying to transfer money to Jack
so these are the three transactions
which are to be initiated
now suppose these transactions were
being happening on a central ledger and
it gets corrupted so there is a chance
of the data getting tampered to solve
this problem a public distributed ledger
plays a vital role now it ensures that
users part of the cycle have a copy of
the transaction details each user will
have a copy of each transaction Bella
John Elsa Jack they all have the same
ledger and this is what is called as
distributed ledger
everyone is having the same copy now in
case one of the users like Elsa missed
places her transaction detail she can
easily be corrected by the other
participants because they have the
golden copy the correct copy or if
either of them attempts to alter the
record the alternate transaction copies
with the other users will negate the
alteration because they will see that
amongst all the participants only one
participant is having a different copy
they will negate the copy of the user
and they will rectify it
encryption blockchain eliminates
unauthorized access by using
cryptographic algorithm sha-256 to
ensure that the blocks are kept secure
so sha-256 is the cryptographic
algorithm which is used each user in the
blockchain has their own keys so any
user which on boards a typical
blockchain network is always provided
with two set of keys one is private one
is public private key is known only to
the sender also it is used to confirm if
the origin of the transaction is
legitimate public key it is also used to
uniquely identify the user but it is
shared by the sender with every
transaction it floats on the blockchain
network and we will see how now let's
take a look at a tip
transaction verification process suppose
a sender wants to send a message he will
pass the message through the hash
function and generate a hash value of
the message now after the hash value is
being created it is passed through a
signature algorithm and with the private
key a digitally signed document is
created now the transaction message
original message the digitally signed
document and the public key are
transmitted to the receiver now at the
receiver end the transaction message is
passed through a hash function to get a
hash value and that hash value is
compared with the hash value obtained by
passing the digital signature and public
key through a verification function and
then both the values are compared now
let's see how the hash function works
the hash function creates a unique
digital fingerprint of data you pass the
message through the hashing function and
it generates a hash value this hash
value is called a digital print it has a
very unique property any hashing
function is a one-way function it cannot
be reversed
you cannot decode the original value
from the hashed value it is a one-way
encryption so here are some examples
whatever be the size of the input data
the hash value is always of 256 bit
length and we will take a look at the
demo at the end of this session where
I'll show you how to generate a hash
value using sha 256 now let's consider
an example of Gmail using hashing
algorithm whenever you are entering the
username and password that password is
never directly persisted in any of the
Gmail's database it is persisted using
hashing function so once you have
created your password and again once you
log in your password is again passed to
the hashing function and compared with
the hash value persisted in the database
and once both these hash value matches
then only you are allowed to load it so
every time you log into Gmail your
password is hashed into a value and
compared against the one stored in the
database the hash value is matched with
the one in database and then the inbox
is displayed on your screen now let's
take a look of what is the proof-of-work
algorithm proof-of-work is
method to validate transactions in a
blockchain network by solving a complex
mathematical puzzle and this whole
process is called mining finding the
nonce value is the mathematical puzzle
that users or miners need to solve in
the Bitcoin network so it takes huge
amount of computational power and
resources of the miner in order to find
out that nuanced value users trying to
solve the puzzle are called miners the
puzzle is solved by determining a nonce
that generates a hash value and results
an output lesser than a target so in any
proof-of-work algorithm there's always a
target which is predefined for a block
the miner has to use the nonce in order
to generate a hash which has to be less
than the target miners verify
transactions within a block and adds the
block to the blockchain when they have
confirmed and verified the transaction
with proof-of-work miners compete
against each other to solve the
mathematical puzzle the first miner who
solves the puzzle is rewarded and when a
block is sold the transactions contained
in a block are also considered valid and
the bitcoins associated with the
transactions then get deducted from the
originator or the sender and moves to
the receiver now let's see how
proof-of-work works so let's take a look
at the block and its components the
previous block hash it stores the hash
value of the previous block of the
blockchain data it contains the list of
all the transactions which have been
aggregated in the block nonce is the
random value which is used to generate a
hash value less than the target and hash
is the digital signature of the block
itself the hash is generated using a
hashing function called sha-256 now
using the nonce when the hash is
generated if its output is less than the
target then the puzzle is deemed to be
solved the block is considered to be
validated if not then the miner
increments the nonce by value 1 and then
in rehashes generate a hash and goes
through the cyclic process till the time
it is not able to generate a hash less
than the target in blockchain the target
is adjusted every to zero one six blocks
which is approximately every 14 days the
average time of block formation is ten
minutes and the difficulty target of the
puzzle increases or decreases depending
on the time it takes to mind the blocks
so it is the inbuilt network which is
generating the target for the puzzle to
get solved and it fluctuates the
difficulty based on the time it takes to
mind block proof-of-work is hard to
produce but very easy for - to verify
the point to be noted here is once the
block is hashed the remaining miners are
supposed to validate the work which one
miner has done but they are not required
to find the nonce again so basically the
miner who's supposed to on the Bitcoin
has done the hard work but the others
miners on the network just have to
verify his validation in blockchain when
miners use their resources time money
electricity etc to validate a new
transaction and record them on the
public ledger they are given a reward
now that reward is in bitcoins itself
which as of today stands at 12 point 5
bitcoins and to add there is no other
way that the bitcoins can be generated
in the Bitcoin network it is only
through mining now the Bitcoin network
internally halves the reward after every
21 K blocks which is approximately every
4 years
so now subsequently whenever the time
period will end the mining reward will
get reduced to 6.25 BTC now let's take a
look at a demo now as I said this is a
demo to showcase how to generate a
sha-256 hash using an input value so
whatever input I have the hash which is
generated it is a 256 bytes even if I
add a new value it will again only
generator 256 bit length hash now let's
take a look at a typical blockchain
structure we have a block over here
which
one transaction added to it now this is
orange in color because it has not been
mine and I can only add a subsequent
block to it once it is mine now as this
is the first block in this particular
blockchain the previous hash value of
this block is all zeros and it is a
called as a Genesis block now as I have
mined this block the hash which is the
digital signature of this block itself
is being generated and I can now add a
block primary thing which to be noted
over here is that the previous hash
value of this new block is the hash
value of the previous block it has two
transaction aggregated in it and I can
again mine it and now the hash of this
block has been generated so this
highlights the typical data structure of
a blockchain and how blocks are linking
themselves to each other now let's take
a look of it typical transaction which
happens over a blockchain now I want to
send money from one at one to wallet too
and I want to send one dollar there is a
transaction fee of 0.1 dollar associated
with this transaction as I have
initiated that transaction wallet 1 has
been deducted as 1.1 dollar and it is a
pending transaction this transaction is
waiting to be mine so I can choose any
of the miners to do this transaction the
pending transaction is done and now
block 2 if you see has been added the
previous hash value of this block is 0 0
e 9 is the hash value of block 1 another
thing to be noted the value of the
amount in wallet 2 has also got
incremented by 1 dot again we can try
another transaction transferring one
dollar again from wallet 1 to wallet 3 +
C from wallet 2 to wallet 3 I have done
a transaction it is spending can be
mined and block 3s but now what are the
key takeaways today we learned what are
the current issues in the banking system
and how Bitcoin solve them what is
blockchain features of blockchain and a
demo of the features which we have seen
I hope you had a great learning session
and I'll meet you in the next session
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here